hi welcome to amigos code my name is
Nelson and in this crash course I'm
gonna teach you everything you need to
know about spring boom spring boot it's
an amazing framework for building java
applications very fast recently Netflix
just announced that they'll be switching
their entire back-end to spring boo
and this is because spring boo is so
solid that there's no need for you to
reinvent the wheel so they provide
things such as connectivity to databases
Jetley servers metrics configuration and
pretty much instead of you having to
configure the low level code to get up
and running you can simply use spring
book and get off the ground very quick
so first I'm going to show you exactly
how to use sprinkle dependency injection
and how to implement to an interface
where we will have an in-memory database
and then I'm going to show you exactly
how to connect to a real database
running on docker
so without further ado let's get started
alright amigos
welcome to amigos code in this video I
want to teach you exactly how to use
spring boat 2.0 spring boat is by far
one of the best frameworks for building
applications in the Java world so if you
want to build an enterprise application
you can use bring pool or if you want to
prototype an idea and see whether you
know it works that you can use spring
book because it makes it very easy to
build applications and basically spring
book provides you a platform for
building back-end applications and only
that you can also build web applications
as well so in this video let's go ahead
and build this awesome API where any
client can submit a request so these
requests could be a get request post
delete and put and then we're gonna take
that request and within the API layer or
control layer so this is where we
receive the requests
we're gonna send that to the service
layer and
the service layer is responsible to
handle all the business logic that you
may have within your application after
you perform some business logic then you
might decide to use a database to
perform some various credit operations
and basically so this layer right here
so this layer is responsible to connect
to any database of your choice so the
cool thing about spring pool and
dependency injection is that you can
start with an implementation and then if
you want to switch to a different
database you simply have to change one
line of code and I'm going to show you
exactly how to do that with dependency
injection so after you submit the actual
request from any client so the clients
could be an iOS app a react or even an
android app the request will go through
all these layers and then go back with a
response to the client so the response
could actually be for example a JSON
payload or an image or a status code of
200 500 so on and so forth so if you
wanna learn the best framework for
building Java applications stick to this
video because there is a lot to cover
and I'm pretty sure that after this
video you will be very comfortable
building back-end applications with
springle so let's go ahead and get
started so the very first thing that I
want you to do is to navigate to this
website start spring doe il and
basically this website you can see that
it's it's titled spring initializer it
basically allows you to bootstrap your
application by picking the penances and
configuring the actual project so go
ahead and generate a project with maven
you can see that you can pick Gradle and
then you have the option to code with
Java code in all groovy so I'm gonna
stick with Java and then for the actual
version make sure that it is above 2.0
so I've got a video on 1.5 and basically
I just want to make sure that you guys
have
latest version so that you can use it
within your latest projects so then go
ahead and click on this link right here
so switch to the full version basically
right here you can you know configure
your project metadata so go ahead and
change these according to your company
or project name but for this tutorial
I'm gonna leave everything as is apart
from the Java version so I'm gonna pick
Java 11 because I do have it installed
but if you don't have to have 11 and go
ahead and pick Java 8 because it will
also work then if you scroll down you
can see that right here we have a bunch
of dependencies and this is why spring
bow is pretty much one of the best Java
frameworks for building applications so
they give you a lot of flexibility with
these dependencies which simply means
that you can install one of these
dependencies and start coding right away
instead of you having to configuring and
you know setting them things so
basically you just have to install these
dependencies and then start implementing
whatever you want so you can see that
they have a bunch of sections right here
so webs or servlet web applications with
spring MVC and Tomcat and Jersey
WebSockets
template engines security so they make
it very easy for you to configure
security within your applications so you
know it saves you the hassle of having
to implement security the right way so
basically they're doing the difficult
job which is implementing the security
and and then giving you this nice
package that you can just plug and play
and then you have SQL so my sequel h2
JDBC Postgres fly away for database
migrations [ __ ] and then you can scroll
down you can see that they have a lot of
great things so for this video right
here let's go ahead and focus on picking
this dependency right here so web server
web applications with spring MVC and
Tomcat so I'm gonna take that and then
generate a project
so right here you see that I've got this
demo zip which I'm going to open in my
desktop there we go
so now I'm going to click on this zip
folder and if I delete the actual zip
you can see that now I have this folder
right here so for this video I'm going
to be using IntelliJ which is by far the
best IDE and if you want to learn about
IntelliJ go ahead and check my video on
YouTube which I show you how to download
install and configure IntelliJ properly
and if you are using NetBeans or Eclipse
this will also work so inside of
IntelliJ so I actually recommend you to
download and install IntelliJ if you
don't have it to follow along and I'm
pretty sure that you're gonna learn
great things with IntelliJ throughout
this video so what I'm gonna do now is
pretty much click on open and then
navigate to desktop and then open up
this demo folder and then open up the
actual palm dot XML so I'm going to open
that up and then open ass project so I'm
gonna allow and just give a second maven
is resolving the dependencies for this
project there we go so that's nice and
done so let's go ahead and explore this
project so open up demo and inside demo
you can see that I have a couple of
folders but the ones that we really care
about are the palm dot XML so if I open
that up and see that this is what you
saw when configuring the project with
spring initializer so you saw the group
ID artifact name and then version so
this is a version right here and then
this is Java 11 basically the actual
dependency that we picked was this one
right here so spring boat starts a web
and by default
springboard ships with spring ball
started tests for writing unit and
integration tests
so go ahead and close this because we
don't need it and open up the source
folder so open up sauce and then main
and you can see that you have Java and
then inside you should have a class
called demo application and inside of
this class you have this public static
void main method and this is how you
pretty much just run your spring
application and if I play so make sure
you play this just give you a second you
should see that I have spring up and
running and you can see that it says
that Tomcat starts it on port 8080 so
right here we could change this port but
this is the default port for Tomcat so
I'm gonna stop this and you can see that
everything is up and running fine so I'm
gonna stop this and then collapse this
and then inside of resources you have
static templates and applications or
properties so static is where all the
web resources live for web applications
and then you have templates and this is
where you have all the templates for
your web application so usually you
would use something like most - or ejs
and then you have this application that
properties so this is where all the
properties for your application do live
and the cool thing about properties is
that you can define properties for
different environments so you could have
a demo environment a test environment
and a production environment with
different values for the actual
properties so it's pretty cool so I'm
gonna cancel out of that and now that
you know the actual structure and make
sure that you can start the application
you've successfully managed to start a
tomcat server with spring book so now
let's go ahead and implement our API
with all of those resources controllers
services and defining a date
bass as well so if I go back to this
diagram so remember that I said we had
the API layer controller or controller
layer and then we have a service layer
for business logic and then database for
data access so let's go ahead and start
things right here so we're gonna start
right here and in fact just let me put a
dot right here so you know what we're
doing so if I remove that basically
let's put just a dot so we know where we
are with things so right here and then
if I collapse that so basically we're
going to implement this section first
and then move our way up so basically
we're going to implement one step at a
time and then see everything working
fine and then implement some other
functionality so let's go ahead and go
back to IntelliJ and the first thing
that I want you to do is to create a
package so let's go ahead and create a
package and right here simply call it
API so this is where the API will live
go ahead and create a second package and
simply save the model go ahead and
create a third package call it service
go ahead and create a fifth package or
actually a fourth package and call it so
we need the actual Dao and I think this
is it so we have API Dao model and
service and basically these packages are
representing this diagram so if I go
back and perhaps you haven't seen me
like right clicking so new and then a
package so basically I tend to use a lot
of keyboard shortcuts and this is how I
am productive with IntelliJ
so if I press ctrl and then enter you
can see the keyboard shortcut down below
and basically then that gives me the
ability to create a new package so the
same if I for example create a variable
so if I say var and then ello equals to
two and and then if I press command and
then Y you can see the keyboard down
below right so I've just deleted that
line so also let me go ahead and say
okay so now what we need to do is
actually define our model so what is the
actual model for this application so if
I go back to this diagram so let's go
ahead and define a model so I'm gonna
copy this stereotype and you can grab
this diagram you can find a link in the
description below where you can download
and see exactly you know everything that
we're doing here so basically the actual
model so loops so the model for this
tutorial will be a person and basically
a person will have an ID so an ID and
let's keep things simple and have like
let's say the full Ashley name just like
that so obviously you could have more
properties but I want to keep it simple
so you see exactly what's happening and
so things you know become really obvious
to you so we have this model right here
called person let's go ahead and define
this in actual code so go back to
IntelliJ and inside of the model package
go ahead and create in your class and
simply call this person right so the
kind it's a class and then press Enter
so now simply go ahead and say private
final and then the ID will be of type
you whit and simply call the ID go ahead
and give us a private final and then
string so this is the actual name
then I'm gonna add these two
constructors so you can see I'm using
keyboard shortcuts again and then the
getters so just like that and there you
go so now we have a model that we can
work with so if I go back so now we have
to define the actual database section
right here right so let's define the
actual interface that will allow us to
have any implementation for our database
so inside of the DAO go ahead and create
a class and then simply say person and
then dao so instead of a class change
this to an interface and this is the
actual interface where we're going to
define the operations allowed or the
actual contract for anyone that wishes
to implement this interface and the cool
thing about it is that we can then use
the penisy injection to switch between
implementations with just one line of
code so let's go ahead and define our
very first method so for our database we
want to insert a person into the actual
database so we will simply return an
integer and basically we're gonna mock a
database using like a list basically we
will return 0 or 1 depending whether the
actual data is persisted to the actual
database so let's simply go ahead and
say insert and then person and this will
take au it which is the actual ID and
then a person just like that and then
end up with semicolon now let's also go
ahead and create a default method and
basically this will be the same thing
actually sorry this will be integer so
it will be the same thing and let's
simply call this ad and then person and
right here we will simply take the
person right and what this allows us to
do is to actually generate the UITs
ourself or there
show ID so you it and then let's call
the ID equals to and then you it dot and
then run them you it and then simply say
return and then insert person passing
the ID and then the actual person yep so
basically we have two methods one that
allows us to insert a person with a
given ID and the other one without an ID
and the idea is simply randomly
generated now let's go ahead and create
a class that will implement this
interface so open up the DAO package and
then simply create a class and call it
person and call it fake and then person
data access and then service and then
this guy implements and then person Dao
just like that and then implement the
methods and we need to implement insert
person right so right here let's go
ahead and define our list so private and
then static and then and then list and
this will be a list of person simply
call it a be equals to a new and then a
red list just like that or in fact we
could even initialize this inside of a
static block if we want it so now to
answer a person all we have to do is
simply add to this database right here
so for the sake of this simply go ahead
and say DB dot and then add and then new
and then person and I simply take the
actual ID and then simply say person
don't and then get name right so and
finally let's simply go ahead and return
one so we know that it always works so
the insertion always works so now let's
go ahead and actually define the
to service so inside of the service
package go ahead and create a new class
and then simply call it person and then
service and right here inside of this
class let's say we have a method to
insert a new person so simply go ahead
and say public and then int and then and
and then person and basically this will
take a person and what we want to do is
simply say return and right here we need
to actually get a reference of the
actual person Dao so let's go ahead and
simply say private and then final and
then person Dao
and make sure that you get the actual
interface and not the concrete class so
don't get the actual fake person data
access service because I want to show
you exactly how to use the penance
injection so then what we need to do is
add this to the constructor and now we
can simply say person Dao don't and then
insert and then person so remember we
had two methods and if I go back to my
interface so person ta oh and in fact I
need to call this the same so let's be
consistent so person so insert person
actually so now you can see that the
error went away so basically we have the
option of providing the ID or not so in
this case let's go ahead and have it you
know randomly generated because we don't
care but if you need to generate the ID
your self you know that you can do it so
now that we have the service done let's
go ahead and implement the actual API so
inside of the API package go ahead and
create class and simply call it person
and then resource oh actually let's go
ahead and say controller so in Springbok
world we tend to name these as
controllers so and then simply say okay
and then let's go ahead and also have a
reference to the actual service so
private final and in-person service
and then right here we need to add this
to the constructor and then let's simply
go ahead and have a method that adds a
person so public and then simply say
void so we don't want to return an
integer in this case so we're going to
so we want to return a status code of
200 or if anything fails we can pretty
much throw an exception so or you could
also have your custom exceptions if you
wish so let's go ahead and simply say
add and then person and this will take a
person so a person just like that and
then what we need to do is actually say
person service dot and then add a person
just like that so up to this point we
simply have normal Java classes and to
be honest we're not even using Spring
Framework at this point so let's go
ahead and configure everything to start
using Spring Framework so let's go ahead
and open up the actual Dao so fake
person data access service and you see
right here inside of the actual service
we have a reference to it so person Dao
and basically we are trying to use the
penance injection so if I was to run
this this would wouldn't work because
this person do is is not instantiated
and you know there's no way for this
constructor to know about it right so
this is where we use annotations to
instantiate beans so open up the fake
person data access service and the way
that we tell spring that this class
needs to be instantiated as a bean so
that we can inject it in other classes
it simply by saying act and then
repository right so you could also say
add and then component so this is the
exact same thing but repository makes it
obvious that this class is served as a
repository right so now that we have a
the tree let's go ahead and configure
the actual service so for service you
might take a guess so this will be act
and then service right and you could
also use at and then component if you
wish but I usually prefer to be you know
specific so anyone looking at my code
know exactly that this is a service so
now that we pretty much annotated the
actual data access service and right
here we are injecting right so we are
injecting into the actual constructor so
the way that we inject is simply saying
at and then Auto wired so basically we
are auto wiring into this interface
right so now because we can have
multiple implementations of this
interface right here we must have a way
to distinguish between them right and
this is when you use at and then
qualifier right so our qualifier and
then right here you can give it a name
so fake and then Dao and basically I
need to go back to my fake person data
access service and then right here I'm
going to name this as fake and then Dao
and what this allows me to do is to have
multiple implementations and basically
all I need to do is for example if I
have for example a Postgres or MongoDB
implementation I simply say [ __ ]
just like that and then I don't have to
change anything so let's go ahead and
use the fake Dao and now this is why it
correctly so finally let's go ahead and
open up the actual API package and then
person controller let's also go ahead
and simply say at and then order wired
and basically Springvale injects the
actual service into this constructor and
if you want to learn more about
dependency injection go ahead and check
my channel I made a video specific on
the police injection and why it's
important for you to know about it so
now
remember that I said that this class
right here so the API if I go back to
our diagram is this one right here
and right here we can specify HTTP
methods so get post delete and put so
these clients right here right so they
have to issue some requests to our
back-end so right now there is no code
that tells that this method right here
will be served as a post or put or get
or delete and also this class is not
available as a rest controller so to do
that we need to use a special annotation
and simply say add and then rest
controller right so this is a rest
controller class that we can have some
methods and then expose some endpoints
that clients can consume so in our case
what we want to do is have this method
right here to be served as a post
request so basically gets is for
retrieving data from your server posts
is to adding a resource to your server
put modifying and then delete for
deleting a resource a resource from your
server so to tell spring that this
method will be used as a post request we
simply use the annotation at and then
post and then mapping and this is all we
have to do now so obviously we want to
add a person from my client right so go
ahead and download postman so postman
allows you to pretty much just serve as
a client because we don't have for
example a react application or an
Android app or you know you we don't
have any any any client right so we can
use postman as our client right so go
ahead and download postman it's an
amazing client and what we need to do is
actually
send a person to our server so before we
do that so let me actually clear
everything here and basically go ahead
and say post and then this will be local
host colum and then 8080 and then for
slash and then simply say api ford slash
and then v1 and then Patterson right so
after you define the actual end point go
ahead to the actual body and then simply
say raw and then instead of text go
ahead and send a JSON so we want to send
a JSON payload to the actual server and
remember we have name and let's say that
this is James and then bond so basically
we want to send James Bond to the server
so in order for us to do that we have to
do few things one is we have to define
these properties in our Pocho so that
when we send this JSON Spring knows to
take this property and then convert that
into a Java class right so in order for
us to do that what we need to do is open
up person so inside of the model package
open a person and then you see right
here in the constructor let's go ahead
and define some properties so I JSON
property and this will be the ID and
then right here so if I put this on the
line at and then Jason property and this
will be the actual name right so you
could also define more properties but as
I said let's keep this simple so that
you understand exactly what's going on
so if I open a postman again so right
here you see that name so this name
right here matches the property that we
have in our class person and if we
wanted to send the ID so we will simply
say ID
and then pass you know a an ID but we
are generating the idea from the server
therefore we don't need to send it now
what I need to do is actually tell that
we are receiving this JSON payload from
the actual body so inside of person
controller go ahead and you see right
here where you add a person so right
here simply annotate this with at and
then request and then body right so we
are simply saying that we want to take
the request body and then shovel that
inside of this person and then because
we have so right here so because we have
the this property right here we will
simply turn this JSON object into a
person that's what we are saying and the
final thing that we have to do is
actually define this path right here
right so right here before rest
controller simply say at and then
request and then mapping and the actual
mapping will be API v1 and then person
so this is all you need to do in order
to create your very first endpoint wait
Springville now what we need to do is
actually test it so let's go ahead and
simply play the application so as you
can see Tomcat started on port 8080 now
if I open up postman and then simply
send this request right here you can see
that we have a 200 status code and this
means that the request went through fine
now obviously we don't have a way of
testing this right because we don't have
an endpoint to retrieve people from our
database so let's go ahead and define
the functionality to get people from our
database so let me
go ahead and open it IntelliJ and if I
collapse that so go ahead and open up
the person Dao and let's go ahead and
say that this will return a list of
person and say select all people and
then let's go ahead and open up the
person data access service so we need to
implement that and then right here what
we need to do is very simple return the
actual database and open up service so
right here simply create a method public
and then list all person get and then
all people and then this will return
person Dao dot and then select all
people so now we need to define the
actual resource or the actual method
that will serve as the get request so
simply say public and then a list of an
in person and then get all people and
then what we're going to return is the
actual person service dot and then get
all people right so now we need to tell
that this method will be served as a get
request and the way that you do it is
simply by saying act and then get and
then mapping so you see that everything
has the same pattern at post mapping at
get mapping now let me go ahead and
pretty much just restart the server
there we go
so the actual server started on port
8080 so open a postman
and then let's actually try and send the
actual same request so we're gonna send
James Bond you can see that worked and
now let's go ahead and try and perform a
get request to our server so the exact
same URL send and there we go so you can
see that we have an array with one
person that comes from our database so
this is awesome
now let's go ahead and perform another
post so so right here so change this to
Nelson and then Mandela you can change
this to whatever name you want to be
honest I'm gonna send that you can see
that it's 200 and then simply change
this to Anna and then Jones send and now
if I perform a get request to our server
you can see that we have three people so
James Bond Nelson and Anna Jones so as
you see Springville is just incredible
it's super fun and as you saw like it
didn't take us long to implement this
functionality right we're just using
annotations to drive our implementation
which is awesome and we can pretty much
deliver results very fast using spring
boom now let's go ahead and implement
the other two HTTP methods the ability
to update a person as well as deleting a
person so open up IntelliJ if I collapse
this and then open up the actual Dao and
let's define the actual interface
marshal method
so right here simply say int and delete
and then person by ID and right here we
need to pass the actual ID so you it and
an ID and let's also define a couple
things so let's also define that we want
to update a person so this will return
an integer and then simply say update
and then person by ID so right here
we're going to pass the actual ID and
the actual new person that we want to
update right
so person and also let's define one more
method and this will be an optional of
and then person and then simply say
select person by and then ID and then
simply pass the actual ID inside and
there we go so now let's go ahead and
open up the fake person data access
service and we have to implement all of
those methods so I'm pressing alt and
then enter and then implement methods
and you can see that we have these three
methods that we need to implement okay
and errors gone so in fact let's go
ahead and implement select person by ID
first so to implement this method what
we need to do is actually search within
our database and see whether we have a
person with the given ID so this one
right here so the way we do it is simply
by streaming our database so let's go
ahead and use Java streams dot and then
stream and if we learn more of our
streams go ahead and check my video on
Java streams where I cover this so let's
go ahead and simply say filter and right
here we get a person and then let's
simply say that person dot and then get
ID dot equals to ID right and then what
we want is dot and then find and then
first and there we go so now let's go
ahead and open up the actual service and
then simply implement the same method
here so public and then this will be an
optional and then person and then get
person by ID
and then simply pass the on show ID and
you can see that it's almost the same
thing that we're doing right here return
and then person Dao don't and then get
or actually select person by ID and then
pass the ID and then open up the
controller so person controller and this
will be a yet so basically we want to
public so this will be a person and then
get and then person by ID and then we're
going to pass the ID and I'm going to
show you exactly how do we get that
so ID and then what we want to do is
simply say return and then person
service dot get person by ID lowercase
ID and then dot or else and then no so
right here you could actually have a
custom message or a custom exception or
a custom code thrown to the actual
client so for example if for for we the
message saying users are not found but
for this video let's go ahead and keep
it simple and simply return no right so
now what we want to do is if I open a
postman is you see this ID right here
right so I want to be able to copy the
ID and then simply say fort slash and
then pass the ID and then when I send
the request I should get that person
back right so the way that we get the ID
from the path is by simply using an
annotation and the annotation is called
so this one is at and then path and then
variable and a path variable that we
want is an ID so ID just like that and
basically this is a type right here so
now let's go ahead and define the actual
mapping so this will be act and then get
and then mapping and now because we want
to have the actual ID in the path
so inside simply say path and then what
you want is double quotes and then curly
brackets and then pass ID so basically
this will allow you to have four slash
and then some ID and then right here
you're simply grabbing the ID and then
turning that into a u it right so let's
go ahead and test this so if I pretty
much just restart the actual server
there we go I've been running so if I
open up postman
now we need to issue some requests so
you can see that you know every time
that we will start the server we lose
everything from our list that's a
disadvantage of having an in-memory
database but for this video you can see
exactly how everything works so let's go
ahead and send a post request there and
then let's get everyone so remove the
actual u it there so send so we have
Nelson right there and basically now we
can grab Nelson's ID and then do a
forward slash and then paste that right
so now if I send you can see that we
have only one object right it so it's
not an array but it's an object and if I
also change the ID for something that
doesn't exist send you can see that
actually it's a bad request because the
you wait it's completely wrong so it's
not valid you with that I've just sent
to the server but you get the idea so if
I go ahead and let's go ahead and add
and a Jones so send and then let's get
everyone and let's grab Anna Jones ID
right there
and then forth / send that you can see
that works right and in fact let me go
ahead and say you with generator and let
me generate you it so I want to one you
with here and if I grab this and then go
back to postman and then perform a get
request wait that you were there so if I
delete everything and then paste I do it
and then send you see that it's a 200
but we have nothing in our database
without you it right so as I said so you
should be thrown in a 404 with a custom
exception but in this video you can see
exactly that we are returning nothing
because there there is no one without
you it against our database so let's go
ahead and implement the remaining
methods so if I collapse this so let's
go ahead and implement everything in one
go now so open up the actual fake person
that access service and to delete a
person what we need to do is simply get
the person if the person is there the
leader otherwise return 0 so let's go
ahead and simply say select and then
person by ID
we're gonna grab the ID and remember
this returns an optional so person and
then maybe and right here I'll simply
say if and then person maybe dot and
then is empty so if it is empty we want
to return 0 otherwise
what we want to do is actually remove
from the database right so if it's there
we want to remove so DB dot and then
remove and then person maybe don't and
then get just like that
and then we turn one right so we know
that we did delete this person now let's
go ahead and implement update person so
what we're going to do is simply say
return and then get or actually select
person by ID we're going to pass the ID
and then what we want to do is say dot
and then map
so right here we get a person let's call
it P so P and as I said if you want to
learn about you know Java streams Maps
operations filtering go ahead and check
my YouTube video where I teach all of
this so now let's go ahead and try and
get the actual index of this person so
int and then index of and then person to
delete equals two and then DB dot and
then index of and then pass the actual
person right so now we have an index so
I'm gonna say if the actual index to
delete and I'm missing an e right there
so if the index to delete is greater or
equal to zero what we want to do is
actually set the actual person so it
means that we found someone right so
let's go ahead and say DB
dot and then set and then index of the
person to delete and then simply pass
the actual person right and now what we
can do is simply return one right here
so otherwise so else or we can simply
say return and then zero and then right
here so because we need to return an
integer simply say don't and then or
else and then zero right
so basically if I format this so
basically I'm saying select the person
and then map that person to something
else right and if the actual index of
that person is greater or equal to zero
we know that
we found that person and then set the
contents of that person to the new
person that we've just received from the
client and then returned one everything
is fine otherwise return zero or if
select person body is not present we
don't do anything and simply return zero
so this is what it means
so now let's go ahead and simply you
know feed these through the service as
well as controller and then test it so
let's go ahead and simply open up person
service so let's go ahead and say public
and then int delete and then person and
then right here we're going to take the
actual ID so ID and then this will be
very simple all we need to do is simply
say return and then person Dao dot and
then delete by ID pass the actual ID and
we're done to update person sorry
so if I close that so to update a person
what we need to do is simply say public
and then end update and in person so
we're going to take the actual ID so you
it and then ID and then this person is
the new person so Neal and then person
right and then what we need to do is
simply say return person the oh don't
and an update and then ID right so you
can see that I don't have much logic
going on here and this is because you
know I'm just teaching you exactly how
to use you know sprinkle to to create an
API but essentially you know inside of
this service you have whatever logic
your application requires right so I'm
just making it simple for you to
understand exactly so you have a lot of
code going on basically you see the
entire process of what we are doing so
now let me go back to the actual person
controller and simply expose those
to a REST API so the first one is update
or actually delete so let's go ahead and
say delete so public and then void and
then delete and then person by ID we
simply pass the ID and pretty much the
same thing at and then path variable and
then this will be the ID and then we
want that to be a you it ID and then
return or actually there's no need to
return here because this is void
so simply say person service dot and
then the lead person party ID now this
has to be guess what at and then
remember we are deleting a resource from
the server so delete and then mapping so
now inside we have to have the path and
then the actual ID right so this ID is
this one right here which we can pass
down to the service so let's also go
ahead and implement the actual update so
the update will be at and then put and
then mapping and public and then void
and then update person and then this
will take a person from the request body
so at and then request body will take a
person to update there we go and now
simply say person service dot and then
update and in fact we also need the
actual path so the path will include the
actual ID so ID and let's go ahead and
say that at and then path and then
variable and that will contain
di D and this will be a youíd and then
call the ID and there we go so now we
can pass ID and then person to update
right and to be honest this is all we
have to do to implement our REST API so
let's go ahead and test it so I'm gonna
pretty much just restart the server so
let me go ahead and open a postman so
let's start with one person so let me
send this request and then let me get
everyone so send you see that we have
Nelson Mandela so let's go ahead and
change Nelson's name to something else
so go ahead and simply create a new
request so go ahead and change this to a
put and the body so instead of saying
and Nelson Mandela let's simply say that
this is Alex and then Colin right and
now let's go ahead and simply pass
Nelson Mandela right here and basically
we just changing his name so if I go
ahead and send you can see that the
request didn't work and now if I get
everyone from our database so if I
perform a get request and then send you
can see that that didn't work and let's
go ahead and debug this in a second but
for now let's go ahead and pretty much
try and delete this person so now some
Mandela so if I put forth slash and then
the actual ID and then delete and then
send we got 200 if we get everyone you
see that Nelson is not there and it's
been deleted so we had a bug so
if I post let's go ahead and post Anna
Jones and basically we couldn't update
the actual name so if I get Anna Jones
get the actual ID and then perform a put
and this will be an adjourns ID just
like that and then body and then let's
simply say update and then update send
still a two hundred but if we get
everyone you'll see that still Anna Joan
so we have a bank so let's go ahead and
try and find out why exactly this is
happening so let me go back to IntelliJ
and then close this and then open up the
actual data access service and now this
is the actual method so we are selecting
the person mapping and then so basically
so right here we have index of person to
delete so this should be actual update
so to update and DB index of person so
basically yes so this is the error so so
right here so you see that we have so
this person right here so this is what
we want to update so right so let me
rename this to update right so the index
of person to update you know it's minus
one so this will always return zero so
what we want is actual P so P is the
actual person and in fact just let me
rename this to person so we want this
person that we found
so person and then this should return
the actual index and then if it's bigger
or equal to zero
what we want is new so because this
update doesn't contain the actual ID so
we need new person and then pass the ID
and then simply say update dot and then
get name so yeah I think this makes more
sense so let's go ahead and restart the
server there we go so now if I open a
postman and then pretty much just yet so
let's start from scratch so no one in
the database let's go ahead and post
anna jones and now we have to get let's
go ahead and get so we get the actual
youíd of anna jones
and then right here let's go ahead and
perform a put to this endpoint and
simply pass anna jones
you with or ID and then in the actual
body let's also change this to Anna and
then Montana just like that and then if
we send so we go 200 and now this should
work so go ahead and send and that uh so
you can see that this now works so you
see that we pretty much just managed to
implement all the methods defined in our
API so it is nice to have like tests for
everything right here and basically I
wrote tests for this class so go ahead
and download the repo down below and you
can run all the tests and see that this
works as expected so I've got unit tests
around all of this so one last thing
that I want to mention is that you see
inside of this person controller right
here so
this person controlled we can have you
know some annotations that enforce null
ability in our application so we can
pretty much just use one some
annotations and enforce that this object
right here is always present and also
valid so go ahead and open a person
model and then right here what we can do
is actually say that this field right
here so the actual name this cannot be
blank so at and then not and then blank
right so the reason why I'm not saying
no is because if you have an empty
string it's no no but if you have a an
empty string it's actually blank so
basically we don't want that to be blank
right so then go back to the actual
controller and now you can say that the
request body so this has to be so at and
then valid right and then we can also
say that this must not be no so we could
also do the same here so we can enforce
that this is valid and also at and then
not know right
so now if I pretty much restart the
server so you see exactly what we're
doing so basically we want to fail as
soon as possible instead of having to
deal with a null ability inside of our
code so now let's go ahead and open up
postman and then let's go ahead and
pretty much try and post someone to our
database so right here so you see that
we have an account but if we send for
example blank so send you see that we
get an error and basically this is
working as expanding as expected so you
see that it's a bad request and it's
pretty much saying that validation fail
for object person right here so this is
awesome and you can see the actual
default message which says that the
field name must not be blank so now if I
go ahead and
add the correct payload so right here so
let's go ahead and say John and then
Jones and then send you can see that we
have way too and your status code and if
I go ahead and get everyone you can see
that we have John Jones so this is it to
be honest so now you should be familiar
with spring boot and writing api's for
your applications so now the cool thing
about it is that you can have a client
API and then do all kinds of things
depending on your application so one
more thing actually that I forgot to
show you is the pendency injection right
so let's say that we want to have a
Postgres implementation right another
database or connecting to a different
database so how do we change that
without changing pretty much anything
apart from one line of code so to do
that what we need to do is open up the
actual Dao package and then simply
create in your class and right here
simply call it for example person let's
call it person and then data access and
then service right let's simply call it
that so this is the real thing now so ok
implements and then person Dao and then
implement all the methods and then right
here so when we select everyone I simply
return list dot and then off and then
new and then person you wait don't run
the MU it and then let's simply say from
Postgres DB right so now what we need to
do is annotate this with at and then
repository and then simply say that this
is a Postgres
implementation right and then to change
our implementation right all we have to
do is grab this name right here and then
go where you inject the actual interface
which is inside of the service right
it's a person service so now instead of
fake Dao
simply use Postgres like that now if I
restart the actual server and then open
a postman now if I perform I get you can
see that we pretty much switched our
database with just one line of code and
you can see that this now is coming from
a Postgres database so I'm actually
trying to do a video on you know
connecting to a real Postgres database
but go ahead and check my channel
because I've got a video on how to spin
up a Postgres container using docker and
also an example with spring boots so go
ahead and check my video on that but I'm
gonna make a second part on this video
connecting to a real database so the
last thing that I'm going to show you
exactly how to spin up everything so go
ahead and stop your server now what I
want to show you is actually how to spin
up the actual jar so this is the the the
jar that you can deploy to a server and
have your application
I've been running so I'm gonna simply
collapse that and then inside of maven
so go ahead and open up this top right
here so maven and you should see a
target folder so if you don't see that
so if I delete that simply go ahead and
open up my cycle and then simply say
install
there we go so this is actually running
some tests and there we go you see that
we have a target folder right here so
inside of the target folder go ahead and
simply right click and then open in
terminal so you should see that we have
this demo
0:01 snapshot jar the jar and this is
what we can pretty much just run on the
actual server right so when you deploy
this to any environment so just to show
you so if I open a post man so if I send
a request you see that the server is not
up and running so to kick off this jar
all you have to do is simply say Java
and right here so if I scroll up you can
see that so if I scroll up you can see
that we can say Java and then - jar and
then pass the actual jar so go ahead and
simply say Java
- and then jar and then the actual jar
so the jar name is demo and then if I
press tab you can see that we get auto
completion and then all I have to do is
press ENTER and you can see that now we
are starting our server so right here
Tomcat started in port 8080 and what I'm
gonna do now simply open up my web
browser and this is the actual API that
you would use so localhost and then 8080
and then API and then V 1 and then
person and then enter and there we go so
you see that we have a JSON that we can
consume and basically you can distribute
this and have thousands of clients
consume your API so I hope you had fun
implementing this application or this
API with Springwood and basically we
achieved everything so we have you know
client so in our case was postman we
implemented get post delete and pull
requests
through the actual controller layer we
had a service layer data access layer
for a database you saw how to implement
an in-memory database and then you saw
how easy it was to switch from databases
and then we returned the actual response
to the actual client which is what you
see right here so as I said I'm going to
do a second part on this video I really
want to add value by connecting to a
real Postgres instance which to be
honest is not going to be a lot of work
as you saw it's just switching one line
of code and then implementing the actual
connectivity to Postgres
so now let's actually go ahead and
pretty much just use actually connect to
a real database the database engine that
we're gonna be using for this second
part of this crash course is this
amazing database engine called pulse
grass so if you don't learn more about
post branches you can go ahead and check
my website where I've got this
PostgreSQL crash course or actually it's
a course about four hours long and it's
absolutely free so you can see the
roadmap right here and I cover the
essentials that you need to know in
order to be familiar with pulse waves
and by far actually by far post price is
the best database out there so go ahead
and check it out go ahead and enroll and
it's absolutely free so if I go back to
the diagram so you can see that right
here we have this data access layer and
instead of talking to a fake database
we're going to connect to a real
database which will be Postgres so for
this database what I'm going to be using
is docker so I'm gonna use docker and
simply say Postgres and go ahead and
click on this very first link and
basically if you don't know about
Postgres and docker or docker and go
ahead and check my video so I've got
this video right here where I cover
about where I cover it docker and
Postgres in about 10 minutes so
everything I'm going to teach you you
can find on this video so if I close
that and basically it's really
straightforward so you can see that they
have some description on what is
Postgres and basically this is how you
start an instance once you have Postgres
installed so let me go ahead and simply
grab this command right here so let me
just grab this command and then go ahead
and open up your terminal I term or
command line so go ahead and simply
open that up and what I'm gonna do is
simply paste that in so actually I
didn't copy that so let me just grab
this and then place that in basically
what we're doing here so just let me
explain so so let's start from the very
first command so docker run so this is
the darker command and then I'm gonna
name this container as so let me simply
rename this to let's say post aggress
and then - the spring and then right
here so - E is the environment variable
so we need that to set the actual
password
so let's simply keep things simple and
simply have a very weak password so
password and then - D Postgres and this
is the actual image and go ahead and
simply change this to post grass and
then alpine so this is the smallest
version and then what we need to do is
also expose a port so we're gonna take
the port that is running inside of that
docker container so 5 4 3 2 and then
expose that to the outside world as 5 4
3 2 so basically what we're doing so
basically this - D is in D touch mode so
as soon as I press ENTER then we can
carry on doing all the things so go
ahead and check my video if you don't
quite understand this because I teach
you all of this so go ahead and simply
press ENTER and there we go so now if I
go ahead and simply say docker and then
PS you can see that we have this
container right here and the name is
post quest spring so go ahead and simply
say docker and then port and then post
an ingress - spring and you can see that
we are exposing the container port to
the outside world on localhost and then
5 4 3 2 and by the way 5 4 3 2 this is a
default port for Postgres so now that we
have
a database so we can log into it and
then perform various things so I'm gonna
show you exactly how to SSH into this
box in a second but for now you have a
container running and exposing a port on
five four three two
so now what we need to do is actually go
and open up IntelliJ and let's actually
connect to this database so what I want
to do is first refer this because I want
to connect to Postgres and what we need
to do is if I actually stop that and
then close that so open up the resources
and by the way I didn't mention that we
have some tests right here so if I open
up tests so you can see that I even took
some time to write some tests to make
sure that everything works so let me go
ahead and close this and then what we're
going to do is open up this application
door properties so application
application doc properties this is where
you define the connection details to
your database so go ahead and pretty
much just delete the application doc
properties so go ahead and delete
applications or properties and inside
what I want really is a file and simply
call it application don't and then
yellow why should I could have simply
rename that to llamo but it's fine so
okay and not for now I'm gonna commit
this in a second so you can have
everything on a branch
so now inside of this application though
ya know this is where we define all the
connection details to our database but
before we do that what we need to do is
actually add some dependencies that will
allow us to connect to databases have
the drivers and then also give us the
ability to write SQL commands against
our database so for that what we need to
do is open up palm dot XML and just let
me collapse this for a second
and you can see some information about
this project I'm using you have 11 the
version of spring boo is 2 point 1 3
release and then you can see that we
have some dependencies right here so
this is the actual dependency for spring
boot start to whip so this gives you
ability to have a tomcat server up in
running and write some API is using
spring boo MVC so on and so forth and
then we have this one right here so
spring will start to test for writing
tests and then we have this except for J
which is pretty much an assertion
library for writing unit tests so the
dependencies that we need are the
following so go ahead and simply add a
new dependency so I'm gonna press ENTER
and you can see that now we can add a
new dependency so the first one that I
need is from all dot Spring Framework
top boot so you see me grabs that and
then paste that in and then the artifact
ID that we need will be spring and then
- and then boot - and then starter and
then - JDBC so let's actually duplicate
this and then what we need is org dot
and then post and then press key well
and then the artifact ID is simply
PostgreSQL so just let me grab that so
that will be that and then what we need
is simply have a scope and then this
will be only at run time and finally we
need another dependency and this time
this will be org dot and then fly away
and I'm gonna explain this in a second
and then DB and then what we need is
simply fly and then way and then core
oh actually - and then core just like
that so all of these dependencies will
allow us to connect to a database and
basically this is what allows us to
write or actually it gives us an awesome
API that we can execute some statements
against our database this is for the
actual driver so PostgreSQL and then
this fly away DB is for database
migrations and you'll see this in a
second so now let me simply go ahead and
open up the project tab and then if I
open up the demo application and then
press play
you should see that we have an error and
the error simply says that failed to
configure data source URL attribute is
not specified and no embedded data
source could be configured so basically
what we need to do now is simply to
create a data source and inject the URL
username and password and then pretty
much allow us to and and pretty much
that will allow us to connect to our
database so let me go ahead and simply
collapse this and what we need to do
first is let's simply go ahead and
create a new package so package and then
simply call it as data and then source
and then go ahead and press ok and
inside of this package let's go ahead
and simply put in your class and then
simply say post grass and then data and
then source press ok and don't ask me
again I will add all of this later on so
this class will be served as a
configuration so at configuration and
what we're gonna do inside of this class
is simply return a data source so public
and then it carry the data source and
let's simply go ahead in any azúcar data
source and what we're gonna do here is
simply return a data source of builder
and inside let's simply go ahead and say
dot and then create and then write here
simply go ahead and say and then simply
go ahead and say dot and then type and
the type for this will be e carry data
source dot and then class and then dot
and then build so you can see that now
we have this data source and what we
need to do is simply say add and then
bean and what we need to do also is say
configuration and then
properties and then what we're gonna do
is simply have app dot and then data and
then source so basically we are
instantiating this Akari data source as
they been and and then what we're going
to do is create some configuration file
that will contain the user name URL
password so on and so forth
so let's go ahead and simply open up the
application dot properties and inside of
application log properties what we need
to do is simply do the following
so let's go ahead and have an app and
property and inside of this app property
we have data and then source and then
inside of data source
what we need is JDBC - URL and this will
be JDBC colon host grass Kewell colon
forward slash localhost and then the
port will be five four three two and
then four slash and then we need to
connect to a database so we're going to
create database in a second but for now
let's simply name this as spring and
then boot and then - and then post Grass
dashdb it's a long name but you get the
point so now we need a username so the
default username that ships with
Postgres it's called Postgres we need
the password so password and remember
the password that we chose was password
and we can also define a pool size so
basically that this is a number of
connections that we can have actively
instead of having to create a new
connection to the database every time
that we want to execute a query every
time we want to execute a query against
our database so I simply go ahead and I
thirty
and that should be it so you can see
that we have app data source and inside
of this data source package we have this
post quest data source and basically
it's just grabbing all the dependencies
from this app and then data source so
just let me go ahead and start this
because I want you to see the errors and
you see exactly what is going on so if I
start the application there we go so now
it says that cannot find migrations in
location class path DB and then
migration so what we need to do is to
create a folder called DB and then
another one called migrations and then
have our database migrations inside it
so what fly and this is basically fly
away right so fly away allows us to
manage our database schema as we evolve
so go ahead and pretty much just learn
about fly way right here so Flyway and
basically you can read through the
documentation but it is straight forward
so just follow along and you'll
understand exactly what I'm doing so if
I close actually I just let me keep that
open so if I go ahead and simply and
close this or actually clear that and
then I've got this time you know right
here so I'm going to open this time you
know and if I do PWD
you can see that inside of desktop
spring boot YouTube crash course so what
I'm gonna do is simply CD into SRC and
then main and then inside of core
resources so inside let me go ahead and
make a folder so make and then there and
what I need is DB CD into DB and then
make another folder so make
dir and then migrations there we go
anta and basically you could have simply
come here and pretty much just right
click and a new and then directory and
then DB dot migrations but I prefer to
use terminal and you should also get
used to it so inside of DB migrations
let's go ahead and create a file and
this file will be as follows so version
1 and the score and the score and then
person table dot SQL so make sure that
this is as follows because otherwise it
won't work so version 1 and the score
and the score person table dot SQL
enter now let me ignore this extension
so this is where we can write some SQL
so let's go ahead and simply create
table person and then inside of this
person we have an ID so ID and this is
of type you it and then this will be not
and then no primary and then key and
then we also have so if I open up the
person class we have the actual name so
if I go back so this will be name and
then this is of our char so let's go
ahead and simply add 100 not know so
this is enough so now we have a table
called person with the following columns
ID and name so what I need to do now is
actually go ahead and create our
database so if I open up the
applications or llamó so remember so
right here we have this database called
spring book post grants dashdb so you
can give it a better name but you know
i'm just giving this name so that you
know exactly what we're doing so what we
need to do now is actually so if i open
up
the terminal and this is where I've got
you know of time some doctor commands
and you saw the how we pretty much just
launched this container which is running
and also exposing this sport so five
four three two so this is the port that
we are connecting right so localhost
five four three two so let's actually go
ahead and bash into a disc on Taylor and
create a database so simply go ahead and
say docker and then exec and then - and
then PI T for interactive and then what
we want is actually if I grab this
container ID and then simply say bin
forward slash and then bash enter and
you can see that now we are inside of
that box or actually and you can see
that now we are inside of this container
right here which we can simply now run
some commands so go ahead and simply say
psql and you can see that we have P SQL
working and now we can write some P SQL
commands again if you've missed my
course on P SQL or actually Postgres so
on my website so this is where I teach
everything that you see me typing and to
be honest you should learn Postgres it's
amazing and a lot of companies are using
it and you can also use it for your
personal project so let me go ahead and
simply go back to my terminal and simply
go ahead and say P SQL - and then copy
to you for post grass so remember so
this is the actual user name and then
enter and there we go so you can see
that now we are inside so if I pretty
much type backslash
and then L so if I clear the screen
backslash L you can see that I do have
three databases so you can see
list of databases we have Postgres
template zero and template one so let's
go ahead and create a new database with
this main so let me grab this and then
if I type three eight
so perhaps so create table actually
database and then paste the name and I
would semicolon enter
oh okay so we can now have - so let me
simply pretty much rename this to demo
DB right so demo and then DB enter and
you can see that worked back slash L and
we have demo DB right here so let's go
back to IntelliJ and let's simply rename
this to demo DB and now what we need to
do is actually connect to this database
so let me connect inside so backslash c
and then demo DB enter and you can see
them connected to demo DB so if I do
backslash and then D so to describe what
we have in here so backslash T we
haven't got anything back /dt you can
see that there is no relations
so these for everything and then DT is
for tables only so now what I'm gonna do
is go back to IntelliJ and let's go
ahead and simply start our application
so then actually go ahead and click on
this icon right here edit configurations
and let's go ahead and simply say that
we only want one sink single instance
running at a time so if you press play
multiple times it means that you will
only get the same process and not get
two processes and then you you get like
when error saying that the pour is
already in you so we don't want that
so go ahead and simply now play and we
have an error and it says cannot find
migrations in classpath DB migration and
that's because I've misspelled migration
have typed migrations instead of
migration so let me rename that so
migration and then we factor there we go
and then start the application and there
we go so you can see that everything
started file and basically right here
you can see that we have Akari pool
started and then completed and then we
have a database demo database right here
and you can see that we have migrating
schema so person table so basically that
was executed so our command was executed
correctly and you can see that the
migration was applied and now we have
the server running on port 8080 which is
awesome so now so if I pretty much go
back to my terminal so I just want to
show you something first
so remember previously we type backslash
D and backslash DT and that wasn't
working actually he was working but we
didn't have any relations so if I type
the same command so backslash D T you
can see that now we have two tables so
this one is for flowery specific which
you shouldn't care at this point but you
can see that we have this table right
here called person and if I go ahead and
describe person so backslash T and then
person you can see that we have this
table called person inside of the public
schema and then the ID is of type u it
not know and then we also have name and
then it's a character varying and then
this is 100 so this is the length and
it's also not know and
this is awesome so if I go ahead and
simply say select and then start from
and then person and that would say my
column and you can see that we have zero
rows so let's go ahead and simply insert
someone so because I know I need to
install an extension to be able to to
generate into it and also I cover this
on my free course I need to install an
extension so what I want to do basically
is this
so select and then you it and then
generate and then v4 as a function and
you can see that no function matches so
what we need to do is create extension
and then this will be you it - OH ssp so
W ID - Oh s SP and now it's my column
enter you can see that worked now if I
pretty much select you with January
version four and you can see that now we
can generate UITs so if i go ahead and
simply say insert into and then person
and then we have ID and the name and
then values and then we want to generate
you it so generate and then v4 and then
the actual name so let's simply say that
this is maria and then jones and then
end out with parenthesis and enter you
can see that marie jones does not exist
and that's because that has to be single
quotes and not double quotes so Marie
Jones like that enter and you can see
that worked so let me go ahead and add
and Tom and then Smith enter now if I
select star from person you can see that
now we have two people inside of our
database and this is awesome so we've
managed to connect to our database using
spring bool and we have a database up
and running with a table and now what we
need to do really is just write some
code to retrieve data from our database
using spring book actually I'm actually
using Java and Springville and their API
basically so let me go ahead and
collapse this and inside of the person
data access service so let's go ahead
and write some code that will retrieve
as everyone from our database so what we
need to do is to use this class right
here so private final and then JDBC
template so what we're gonna do is add
this to constructor and then also wire
so this is dependency injection we don't
have to do anything
spring spring boot knows how to
initialize correctly this class for us
so that we can write some code against
our database so now instead of saying
select all people and then return a list
so basically this fake list what we're
gonna do is use JDBC template API so
simply go ahead and say JDBC template
dot and you can see that they have
various methods so the one that we want
is query so we want to query and the
query takes two things so we can pass s
so we can pass an SQL statement and then
we have to pass a row mapper so
basically the block mapper is how we
take the values that we retrieve from
our database and then transform that
into a Java object
so let me go ahead and simply simply
define a string so string and let's go
ahead and make this final not needed but
point O so SQL equals to select so
basically the same thing that we had so
select name Oh actually this is ID name
and then from and then person not the
same so previously we simply said select
star so right here so select star so
select and then ID name from person and
this is the same thing so I I prefer to
use the actual column names instead of
the instead of star so now let's go
ahead and simply pass the SQL query so
xql and now we have to pass this row
mapper so this bro mapper is a lambda
that has access to the result set to the
result set as well as the index so what
we're gonna do inside here so let's
simply go ahead and say return and then
we need to return a person object so
person so this is our model and inside
of our person we need to pass what we
need to pass the youíd so this should be
new person just like that so inside you
can see that we have to pass a u it and
also a name so inside of the results
sent we can get the string so get string
and then you can see that we can pass
the column label so I know the column
label is so basically it's ID and also
we can get the actual name so resolve
set dot and then get string and then
this will be named so if I put this this
on a new line and you can see exactly
what we're doing so right here you can
see that we have an error and this is
because this result said I'll get
string is a string basically and what we
need is a you wit type so I simply go
ahead do it and then from string and
then we need that so that will work so
you can see that now this works let's
end up with semicolon and what I like to
do is actually to extract this way
variable so all of that actually and
then this will be ID and then this will
be name so you see exactly what's
happening and we can remove that and
also that and then that and then format
everything so now I don't need to return
the list of pretty much just fake people
so this from Postgres DB is not name and
we are retrieving from a database so you
can see that I still have an error and
this returns a list of people right so
you can see that's a list of people so I
can either say return and then people
oops so people just like that or I can
simply return that in line so we factor
and there we go so you can see that I'm
returning that in line which is awesome
so this is it so if I now restart the
application so let me go ahead and
simply say stop and rerun there we go
it's up and running and if I open up
Chrome and then remember so right here
we previously add an empty list and this
is because he was coming from our fake
database so now if i refresh this there
we go
so you can see that now this is coming
from our database and this is awesome
guys so you can see the power of Spring
boo basically you can just write code
you know very fast and they give you
these tools so that you can focus on
writing what matters instead of you
having to configure things so there we
go so let me go ahead and simply add
someone else into this table so let's go
ahead and simply say Tomcat actually no
it's okay let's simply say Ana and then
Jamil and an enter so if i refresh this
you can see that now we have a ninja mil
so there we go
if I collapse this you can see that this
is only one implementation of our API
right so we have a bunch of other
methods
so select person by ID actually let's go
ahead and implement this one quickly so
you see exactly how this is done so what
you want is to pass and Ashley select ID
name from person and then here you can
say we're in an ID equals two question
mark
and then what you want is to take the
exact same thing here and then simply
return that but instead of query because
query returns you a list what you want
is query for and an object and query for
object takes the SQL but we also need to
pass the arguments so new object so this
must be an array so just like that and
you can see that so currently this is
empty right but I need to pass this ID
that comes from the client so ID and
then this let's rename this because it's
already in scope so person and then ID
and let's rename that to person ID as
well just like that and let's actually
change this so this will be
a person right but what we want really
is to return so return optional dot of
nullable because that can be no and then
past person just like that so basically
it's the same thing but we have this
question mark and then query for object
we pass the ID right here so if I put
this on a new line so you can see
exactly what we're doing
so in than that so we pass the SQL the
ID and basically if you had more
argument arguments you'd simply pass
them right here so we have the ID and
then this is the role mapper as you saw
before so right here and then we simply
return the optional of nullable of
person because you know we might not
find a student with a given ID so if I
restart this and then open up Chrome so
if i refresh you can see that this still
works but if I now take this ID and then
pretty much to four slash and then ID
remove the quotes there enter and you
can see that now we only get one person
and this is awesome so there we go so
you can see that we managed to connect
to a database using docker Postgres
flyweight spring JDBC and you can see
that this was pretty much you know very
straightforward and we even managed to
use Akari so I didn't even explain what
Kari was but Kari is the actual
recommended data source are you should
be using for spring book because it's
very fast reliable and yeah it's just
one of the best ones out there so there
we go guys if you have any questions on
this and basically I'm gonna let you
implement the rest of the logic so
insert person
the same with delete and then update but
basically it is straightforward using
some SQL so go ahead and pretty much
just subscribe to my channel to get more
videos like this if you want to learn
more about all of this and more so I've
got a spring book full stack web
development course where I teach all of
this and a lot more and also creating
user interface for this using react GX
and hooks and pretty much it's a lot of
content packed into one course where I'm
pretty sure that once you learned that
you will be able to build applications
on your own and also apply for jobs
because a lot of companies are looking
for a springboard developers or you know
Java developers but spring bow is used
quite a lot in the industry and once you
know all of these skills so dependency
injection connecting to databases
writing tests writing integration tests
writing user interface for it I'm pretty
sure that you will be able to get a job
okie-dokie
as you saw throughout this crash course
spring book is amazing so we really just
scratched the surface and the next step
for you is to check out my full stack
web development spring boot and react
and in that course I'm going to teach
you everything you need to know about
spring boots so we're going to cover
essential topics that you need to know
as a software developer and the cool
thing about this course is that whatever
you learn you will be deploying it into
a real server using Amazon Elastic
Beanstalk and upon completion the skills
are quiet in this course it will help
you apply for jobs because it will help
you with a lot of great important
concepts that a software engineer should
know also you can start your own
projects University projects and pretty
much if you are a developer you should
be aware of this awesome
and how to use it inside out this is all
for now go ahead and check out my
youtube channel where I've got more
content similar to this it was a
pleasure teaching you and I'll catch you
in the next one see ya